Safe to use a vacuum sealer on food. Yeah, yeah, I think so. I mean, so quite honestly, you know,
if you're on Instagram or Facebook and you're in any health groups, I mean, let's be honest, you
hear bad things about every day. It just gets to the point where it's like you can't leave it
because you know, there's bad things and everything. You have to have a balance. You just have to,
you're going to go crazy. So yes, would it be better if you just put everything in glass and
and did that. Yeah, but you know, are you storing the plastics in a heated space? Yes, I'm storing
the plastics in a hot, you know, garage. Whether it's probably not best to put foods in plastics,
are you putting it in a cold area, a cool area? Yes. Well, you're not going to have a lot of
leach of bad chemicals from the plastics where you have a lot of leach of bad chemicals from plastics
with heat. So like the plastic top on your coffee cup, that's good. So leaving your water bottle,
your plastic water bottles that you got from Costco in the car in the summer, not good.
But you know, it's just a matter of trying to find whatever balance is best for you. Do I eat sugar?
Yes, I do because I like it. Should I know? But you have to find the balance that's best for you. And
that beats yourself up. You know, I said over and over again, this is, you know, your diet and your
lifestyle cannot become a religion that it's an, that it's idolatry. And that's not healthy.
That's really not healthy. So you have to find that balance of what's good, what's right, to use,
you know, common sense, use knowledge and science that we know of today. So we, you know, we're
really big into our garden needed stuff. My wife and I, we make this chinchuri sauce. That's great
over chicken and vegetables and all sorts of, you can just put it on anything, crock pot meals.
It's so good. But we put it in Ziploc bags and freeze it. It would be better if you can't it.
Yeah, but then you have to have, then you have to pressure can it. And this just takes a bunch of,
so when you're canning and doing so many things during, you know, harvest season is insane in our
house. And you just have to balance things out. I don't think we're getting a lot of estrogen
disruptors from our Ziploc bags that we're putting in the freezer. I don't know, maybe science is
going to say that's the worst thing that will change our ways. But right now I don't think it is. And
we're going to go with it. So it's just about having that balance. We used to use the vacancy
there. And there was going to be as hard as it was to the pretty good. We used the vacancy there
and other things. So there's a little bit of longer shelf life. So yeah.